focus
if you want to have success as an
entrepreneur you need to stay focused on
your business and not jump from idea to
idea to idea and never seen anything
through
hi i'm evan carmichael i believe that
hungry entrepreneurs deserve help and
entrepreneurs have add
you jump from one idea to another idea
to another idea and we're addicted to
the new we like new things
but we don't see
our ideas through
and that's a problem
if you're like that
then you're never going to build a
successful business
as soon as a new idea gets boring you
jump to something new
and you don't see things through you
don't let momentum to build you don't
build a successful company i'm reminded
of a camping trip i took a couple weeks
ago
and uh
i haven't been camping for like 20 years
and i was in charge of the fire so
everybody had their role my role was
build fire
and so i got it all set up the paper the
twigs the kindling the big log set it up
beautiful
it's finally time to light it i strike
one match watch the whole thing burst
into flames awesome feeling
but once the fire was roaring
i didn't really care about maintaining
it i left that to the other people in
the group you know they like doing that
it's fine whatever i don't care i just
like seeing it take off
and that's a problem with a lot of
entrepreneurs
we'd light little fires everywhere
instead of focusing on one big fire and
turn it into a huge bonfire
that's what you need to do with your
business not just like tiny little
businesses everywhere like a little
arsonist you've got to focus on one
thing find your passion find something
that helps people and focus on that
business see it through stay committed
don't get distracted
by all these other ideas around you
i know it's hard i know i know a lot of
entrepreneurs have entrepreneur add but
you need to stay focused you got to stay
on task
i'm reminded of a quote i want to read
you a quote from andrew carnegie now
andrew carnegie
was the richest man in the world
and somebody asked him
what
led to your success
what can i as an entrepreneur do to be
successful i want to be successful like
you mr carnegie you're the richest man
in the world what made you successful
here was his number one tip for
entrepreneurs okay have i built it up
enough this is important here's what he
said here is the prime condition for
success
the great secret
concentrate your energy your thought
your capital exclusively upon the
business in which you are engaged
having begun in one line resolve to
fight it out on that line to lead in it
to adopt every improvement have the best
machinery and know the most about it
the men who have succeeded are men who
have chosen one line and stuck to it
i couldn't say it any better focus guys
it's important
for those of you watching if you like
this video please give it a thumbs up
below it makes me want to do more for
you and i want to hear what you have to
think are you focused is this a problem
for you do you have another question
that i can answer for you please leave
it in the comments below i really read
those every day i love seeing them come
in thank you so much and i'll see you on
the next episode